- Des forêts moins vertes,
des arbres décimés
de leur feuillage.
La chenille spongieuse
européennes fait des ravages
cette année. On les trouve par
dizaines, accrochées aux arbres.
- On en a pas vu autant l'an
passé. Non. Cette année, c'est
plus remarqué.
- Elles se promenaient vraiment
sur les roches. Moi, ce qui
m'étonne, ça fait deux semaines
de suite que je vois ça.
- Elles s'attaquent
particulièrement aux bouleaux et
aux chênes, mais mais raffolent
également des conifères.
PIERRE THERRIEN, Entomologiste,
service des insectes ravageurs
- L'année prochaine, ils vont
être encore en vie, il ne faut
pas penser que les arbres sont
morts parce qu'il n'y a plus
de feuillage. Pour les
conifères, sapins, pins,
épinettes, c'est plus difficile,
il peuvent mourir en une année.
- Cette invasion se voit un peu
partout au Québec et ailleurs au
Canada. La spongieuse a défolié
près de 600 000 hectares
de forêt en Ontario en 2020.
LUC BOUTHILLER, professeur
de politique forestière, ULaval
- Normalement, ce ne devrait pas
être préoccupant, puisque
le phénomène qu'on observe cette
année, c'est une conséquence
d'un hiver relativement clément.
- Avec ses longs poils et
ses points bleus et rouges,
la spongieuse n'est pas toxique.
Mais un contact avec la peau
peut causer des démangeaisons.
Importée en Amérique du Nord
il y a plus de 100 ans par
un entrepreneur français,
elle s'est implantée de manière
permanente aux États-Unis,
faute de prédateurs.
- Il y a quand même une bonne
nouvelle. Il y a certaines
variétés de champignons qui est
apparu dans les dernières années
aux États-Unis et qui exercent
une prédation sur...
les spongieuses.
- Selon quelques experts, il n'y
a pas lieu de s'inquiéter pour
le moment puisque le phénomène
est cyclique. Mais les
changements climatiques
pourraient entraîner des hivers
plus doux et ainsi contribuer
à leur prolifération.
Ici Marie Isabelle Rochon,